- [Instructor] We are told
Ismael made a scaled copy
of the following quadrilateral.
He used a scale factor
less than one, all right.
And then they say what could be the length
of the side that corresponds to AD?
So AD is right over here.
AD has length 16 units in
our original quadrilateral.
What could be the length of the side
that corresponds with
AD on the scaled copy
of the quadrilateral?
So it's a scale factor less than one.
So we're gonna get something
that is less than 16
for that side.
And the rest of it will all
be scaled by the same factor.
So the resulting quadrilateral
might look something,
might look something like this.
This is just my hand-drawn version.
So the key realization is
is if our scale factor is less than one,
this thing right over here is going to be
less than 16 units.
So let's look at the choices.
And it says choose three answers.
So pause the video.
Which of these would match
if we're scaling by a
factor of less than one?
Well, we just have to see which of these
are less than 16 units.
This is less than 16.
And those are the only
three that are less than 16.
32 units, this would be
a scale factor of two.
64 units, this would be
a scale factor of four,
clearly a scale factor
that is not less than one.